um hello guys uh
i'm back again uh dylan and uh
today uh i'm gonna be showing you my
refined forming system
uh this is much simpler it uses normal
pistons instead of sticky pistons the
layout is a lot simpler not as complex
i even made it underground
and the redstone isn't as complicated
so first i'm going to show you the
floodgates
the floodgates are normal pistons that
are activated to hold the water back
a single
source block of water
and they're hooked up
to a single red stone trail
by this lever
basically the lever hits off the first
repeater
and then splits off to the first piston
and then it comes up hits another
repeater and goes all the way to the
other piston around that corner
now to show you it
how it works also
i made it uh three wide rather than two
so you can get more wheat
uh you can get 90
uh fit 90 wheat on here
90 wheat 90 plants on here whatever you
want to call it
i don't know what you want to call it
but basically when you turn this off uh
floodgates open
and
you can walk along here to collect the
items
rather than walking in the water
and um
basically that's it uh you could also
use this for mushroom farms
uh
you know
whatever you want
so i hope that was helpful
and um goodbye